fantastic i think the council has done a
great job there
it's really really good it seems to be
ginormous it's
a long way back to the back to see who's
there
for later so that's good for them right
welcome we've got apologies from
liz smith and welcome to chairman yeah
okay
so
with those apologies noted uh some would
prepare the move to be accepted kirsten
monique i'll put that all those in favor
please say hi all right to carry
conflicts of interest do we have any
conflicts 6.2 6.24
robbie and robbie
minis are there any corrections to
the minutes it seems some time ago of
course not didn't have a meeting last
one
okay there's someone prepared to move a
confirmation
move by paul seconded by jason
put that all those in favor please say
all right
okay
any matters
i arising think so
we have no reputations for presentations
we have no mature business
so we'll move on to reports 6.1
charles upping drive
chain welcome shane that's pages 18 to
24 and
for shane start so
just tell the board that
i attended i think both the meetings we
we had there
and don't cut right i thought did a very
very good job of bringing the parties
together
so did you say over to you
and i will second that certainly he has
a good sense of the community he's
working with there so for those of you
i've not yet met i am the transport
engineer for council taking over after
bill rice already had put some effort i
think towards working
through problems
or certain concerns i guess have been
raised over on charleston drive as you
know it cuts right through the middle of
the retirement village and there have
been a number of concerns expressed over
uh the interlocking factors of parking
access to the driveways on the west side
pedestrian circulation and driver speed
and council is also working
independently of this on the connection
charles up and drive through the
huntington which will be increasing the
amount of traffic the future that is
completed
you'll see how that impacts speeds my
guess is that would probably have a
negative impact there too but uh we'll
put a pin in that for a moment
so with that being said i will reach out
and work with david and jim appreciate
your presence at the meetings as well
and the residents along charles up them
so we have sort of a package of
improvements we're looking for
your approval on primarily on the west
side we are going to be removing one
parking space between each of the
driveways to open up a little bit more
space
so that residents exiting the apartments
on the west side can see cars coming
from a bit further on
independent as well we are looking at
extending footpaths and sort of
reconfiguring some of the pedestrian
connections
from the new daycare center down to the
south and the drive all the way up to
the new connection
at uh salisbury in valor
primary i think just though really will
be a little bit of that um
rationalization of parking on the west
side the other part to that too then as
well is we actually will be marking with
the brackets and the white markings that
delineate actual parking stalls and that
we hope will actually try to discourage
people from trying to squeeze into a
spot that might not necessarily be the
right size for their car or blocking off
some of that site that's from
the residents trying to exit from inside
one ancillary
bits that brings your attention as well
there is a resident
in an apartment towards the south end of
the complex
who made a request while we were
reaching out and consulting to see about
getting a
designated reserve mobility car park on
the street um so we could go ahead and
take one of the design stalls and do
that i think it would be our
recommendation
that we don't set a precedent for
setting aside
in residential areas
reserved car parks for mobility needs
there obviously are good needs in
high-tech areas like high street for
example but
i think this may not be the best
application for something like that
i have to say that
during the discussions there and with
the residents
and there was almost total unanimity for
the recommendations that are coming
forward there was one lady that wasn't
totally happy but
she has the feeling i thought that
she she thought that road was private
and the lot belonged to charles up and
it wasn't a public road so that was just
a slight
difference but
right so
questions
paul
i i know to say grove is actually quite
utilizing parking now
are there places there where they
the cars the spots are going to lose
parking are there any other places for
those people to pack or we're gonna
create congestion somewhere else
so there is a reasonably high parking
demand driven by the retirement village
um my understanding is it's in a large
part of the staff
because there is a reasonable
parking on site
so that parking demand and presence
stretches up charles open past the north
end of the retirement village but
typically does not go all the way up to
helm so i think we're looking at moving
four five parking stalls so that would
migrate further
along charles album
there is presently footpath on the east
side
that is where the parking chiefly um
exists on that side of that north end of
charleston there will be the future of
the mountain on the west side as well
future development so
it will be extending
staff and public parking further north
um but we don't expect it to go any
further than now which is
basically the presence
well i support this is it worthwhile
because it's a
child button
problem staff and that is it worthwhile
making it to the uh management if they
can get your staff to
park a wee bit further away from their
context um
um and alleviate some of the problems
for some of these people as well has
that been discussed with them
so my understanding of conversations
with david cartwright who is the
resident village manager is that the
direction of staff is to try to avoid
parking within the stretch that fronts
the residents apartments so i believe
the parking utilization area
in theory should be primarily residents
um we have not done any
um serving example but that's my receipt
although i think it's fair to say that
they can't run to say that they expect
staff to park up towards elm drive
and on the left as you come down
there are a couple of entrances into the
houses on the left or apartments on the
left and both those entrances have
visited car parks
uh on both sides of short drive and
they're always spaced there for visitors
i visited there quite a bit mr actually
was alive and never
[Applause]
and just on that um having sold down
there
you've talked about charles up and drive
but have you consulted any of the new
residents at the other end of charles up
and drive to let them know what's
happening in
[Music]
about six houses now being built in
there
so we uh
at this point have only consulted with
the residents of the retirement village
because the changes we're looking at are
chiefly in the central part of the
retirement village
it is our expectation that there will be
major impacts to through traffic so the
residents who are further north of the
target village should still have
shouldn't see much of a change to their
travel through the retirement village
i will say though
while within that topic we will be
looking at the possibility of putting in
some islands for refuges for the
pedestrian crossings so
again looking at that as a needs to
encourage problems
behavior in terms of speed and attention
um
but we don't expect there to be any
effects to be felt further north
specifically of the parking
now as far as the connection for the
north that being a separate project i
think
back to that but that's down the road
so the residents at the other end will
be notified when you're doing the island
because there'll be obviously some
disruption to them
we absolutely
do our best to minimize disruptions
absolutely so
the second question i've got is about
the crossing point on the corner
near the cafe in day here
and obviously that's a little that
you're looking at putting an island in
there
why wouldn't you put a raised more
raised
crossing bay there to sort of delineate
that it's an entrance into a retirement
area to help the traffic to get that
feeling that there's a change in the
environment
i think charles oven would be a great
location for raised crossings
it conveys a lot of water
in the arrangements and that becomes a
real limiting factor and that was what
was driving us um to try to come up with
other means to
um
encourage
slower speeds and protect the pedestrian
crossings
without impeding the water that's coming
down from arlington and points north
it's an overland flow
and that that's not real driving after
that was a real constraint but isn't
putting the crossing point on a corner
quite dangerous
because you have less visibility around
that corner so there will be um some
extension of the stopping lines with uh
related to the pedestrian crossing here
um the fact that it's a short distance
north of the trail from oxford um and at
the oxford charles open intersection
charles loping and acacia have gateway
control so i don't expect through
traffic to be coming with great speed
there and it's location right on the
corner you should be able to have
sidelines
and i noted in
4.1.4 you said there's been no
crash history potent possibly because of
the low speed
environment were you aware of the amount
of numbers
of their misses of vehicles coming out
of
the driveways and residents walking
across the road without falling in their
areas
there was anecdotal
talk of that but that is not something
that is very challenging for there to be
a quantitative record of that so um
i'll feel it too
good just going down that road myself
yeah um
so
is there a case for another crossing
point a little further along because the
main problem you have is people
jaywalking across to those resident
trainers
we had some conversation around
there's a central crossing point
immediately jason to the main village
center and that is from
my great understanding the main focal
point for people traveling
um and there was a conversation around
whether there would be uh
whether that was an appropriate location
for his number crossing
um and
our sense from speaking with residents
meeting with david and being on the site
was that there wasn't going to be
not traffic
enough pedestrian traffic to just by
putting in
priority crossing for pedestrians
given that i understand that there is
a dispersion of attractions on the west
side of all the apartments um i think we
would probably still like to have
the one crossing point near the entry to
the village because on the east side you
still have just one destination um and
rather than encouraging uh
people crossing the multiple points
along that stretch having them cross at
that one location immediately adjacent
to the east side is probably the best
location
we will be looking at again taking that
crossing point further north
around the bend which is midpoint and
not an ideal location and extending that
for over
um
i think something we intend to be
keeping an eye on charles albright for
speeds
especially after we put that final
connection through we'll also keep an
eye on how pedestrian traffic is
interacting with
um in the traffic as it fluctuates
through there so i think that's that's
any other question tomorrow
just as long as we can keep the actual
staff or ryan actually parked around
their place as opposed to
encroaching
[Music]
um there there should be room i believe
i should caveat that by saying i have
haven't measured the carriageway but now
drive is doesn't historically have as
much of a parking issue so i think that
should be that should not be an uh
problem to have more staff parking there
i think the element that i'm a little
unclear on is i'm not sure if there is
access off of you know dry frontage to
get into charles upton village or if
they would staff and still have to walk
down the path how to travel something
all the way down um i think that's worth
i can take that off
it would be just a short walk across
your own park
straight into the buildings and
everything shows up
down
that's quite a good point
paul
just one more question because uh alarm
bells are arrived in the summary if
you're going to put in extra pedestrian
crossings and here
we'll raise platforms is that going to
take away
more car parks later on or will you put
in those pedestrian crossings and areas
where you've taken a car park away from
there so the pedestrian crossings
to the pedestrian crossings exist at
present and um
the central pedestrian crossing already
has curve
extensions so there will be no change to
parking there
the south pedestrian crossing which is
closer to the daycare in the cafe
doesn't
have there is a no stopping apartment
that will be a little longer because we
put it
in there
um but there there has not been
traditional parking demand there because
there's no development on the southwest
corner as that has now opened that area
is a little bit flux i think
the north end will be removing um the
pedestrian crossing where the footpath
ends the present and shifting it further
north to where future develop will be
occurring where i guess with chatsworth
drive to the intersection there and
because it's going to be placed at the
intersection there should be
a limited impacts department because
it's immediately at the intersection
department sorry
there's no exactly moved
because of the key strength
um so on the north end
i haven't seen the final design there's
a chance there could be a car park or
two impacted there on the south end i
think there may be
off the checkered lakes i think the
south and there might be a couple spots
removed because of the island because my
concern was we're kind of moving some of
these parks
further down both directions possibly
and um
yeah i just don't want to see some of
the
residential properties impacted that um
further down the road all day parking
and
et cetera that's my concern
and i would say
at the north atlantic so that there was
a possibility pending up inside there
could be a car parked but to the
intersection of chatsworth and charles
sullivan um that is not the location
that a president that is the parking
there is primarily from
the staff forward
let's start for the retirement village
and that is what the eastern frontage is
the western frontage will be developed
in the future
concerning exactly what that will look
like
down to the south there is a residence
down there it's just um
signs that indicate elderly crossing or
no i'm not putting down this road oh
she's going to cause problems
no
yes there are signs out there they are
supposed to say
aged and they say elderly it's one or
the other they don't have the exact
problems
right we've got a recommendation someone
prepared to move
we've moved back all secondly by robbie
you wish you speak to it
no
yeah
just because the residents actually want
to see it that's why i'm
moving this motion but i just
i am concerned about us limiting parks
around the place and i hate to see us um
creating a problem in a different area
and to the north a lot of those people
are still building their houses and not
in there yet
and i'd hate to have
them coming back to us
we bought this place here we've never
used people parking there
all of a sudden because we've done this
they can't have any visitors parking out
there
so
i think every time we do something like
this we're going to be weary of taking
car parks away from the
area and it's
it's not just the area
we were taken from the flow on effect
further down the road that i'm really
concerned about um
but um yeah it's
the safety factor
at the moment i realised
yes this is a very very necessary
movement i have seen quite a few
dangerous situations
and elderly people are a little bit more
tentative with their driving would tend
to be
and
they are slower across the road and
for the unwary driver they step out from
behind the park car can be very very
dangerous and i've seen that actually
hit them in this area
i would have preferred to have a few
raised platforms to befriend just to
encourage drivers to travel at a slower
speed um as soon as you open up the
other end it is going to create some um
through traffic to ireland to the shops
and so i think that's something that
we'll have to look into whether there is
a drainage solution that we can come up
with um by having some sort of raised or
um
something a change or two from the
online even if it's just cobblestones
something like that too so that people
actually feel that they're entering a
different environment i have a similar
consumer poor head about pushing the
problem further north
into the residential area without
consulting those residents i think it's
really important that we always look at
these problems
and
now that we have people living there
it's important to talk to them as well
and keep them fully informed about the
change of worth but i am satisfied that
it really only does go down to elm drive
except when the menu has a large
income and it does then push out but
those are few and far between and i
think it should actually signal to all
developers of retirement villages the
need for ex better parking for these
staff in particular um
the this problem has been created
because the village had no parking
and so therefore it's actually caused
danger to be residents
and so i think a sensible developer
needs to look at that
whether their parking needed to be off
the road indented or other solutions
when they designed it and that might
have made it easier for our residents to
cross
when they situate
part of the village on one side of the
road and part on the other side of the
room they need to make sure that it's
fully integrated so that they can get
across there
so i think the solutions come up i
really really congratulate start on
finding some good solutions i think
there's more to be done and i think the
through road will probably trigger some
more talk
and i would encourage that that
conversation is held with the resident
of the surrounding area as well as the
village so that we can make sure that
everybody is on board with the changes
okay any anyone else
there's nothing to reply to so i'll put
the recommendations all those who pay
for please say all right
carrie thank you shane don't go away
because you're up again item 6.2 pages
25 to 29
stops shine
so we are looking to change a number of
locations that present have give away
priority control to stop controls
specifically because there are
visibility issues
but if you're for instance one of these
is right around the corner from charles
altman it's an i'll drive an oatwood
drive where there is a large
retaining wall on the northwest corner
of the block's visibility as you come up
to the intersection uh the rules or
rather the guidance in terms of what
makes for a safer intercession to
approach
and judging to give away
if you measure nine meters back from the
lender line if you cannot see the sight
distance up in one direction or the
other then you really should be aiming
for stop control
as well just to try to minimize
confusion with drivers we find it's best
practice to have the same type of
control on both sides
so while you might have an intersection
that has a conflict on one side of the
propellant drive at local drive is a
good example
on the east side you actually have
reason a good sight distance uh it does
we don't like to have
uh motorists coming up and maybe a
little bit confused as to whether they
have to come to a complete stop or just
get away so we tend to find this best
practice if you're switching to stock
control on one side to do it on the
other side as well so the three
locations we're looking at again elm
drive at open drive
layman's road at johns road which has
been uh in the news a little bit late um
and so that would be the north and south
approaches of layman's well john
has through priority and then
layman's road when it comes to a team
recession and side
the northwest corner sorry
sorry northeast corner you have a
visibility issue with the hedge there uh
i want you to solve your problem the
stop sign is probably the best
um
it seems to have worked the one from
john drew baskets road the way they've
done that with the flesh and lights and
the
thing of the
it's just it's unfortunate it's not the
road's problem it's actually drivers but
this is possibly the best way to
sort the other issue just my concern is
though
is this going to be temporary because my
understanding is this is when they're
going to be bypass
and the bypass is going to have two stop
signs in a good way all this hardness
bypass
so layman's is intended in the future to
be a
major bypass i think we will need to be
taking a closer look not just at this
intersection because it would make sense
to reconsider the priority which
direction has the
will become primarily but then further
um at john's placket
that complex intersection as well so the
two of them are again on our radar
but at this point john still has the
bulk of the traffic so we see that
change in the future i think
i hesitate to use the word temporary
i think maybe short to medium term i
don't necessarily have a sense of when
we'll be in a position
to have layman's having so much traffic
we'll be looking at switching it but i
think that is definitely something that
will happen in the future but not in the
next couple of years is my sense of it
at least
other questions
um you may mention
in the two or three ones you've
mentioned that there's the
hedges and the blockages in the wall was
accepted that obviously indicates
you know
issues with traffic so they come to a
stop now they have more time
so
is that hazard
can be mitigated or is the fact the fact
that they stop have more time to
actually look it has it all or should
have been removed
[Applause]
if in any location where the hazard is
within the roading reserve and it's a
fairly simple magnitude
we would do that before going to stock
control
in all three of these locations
visibility impairment is actually a
private property and so it's not a
simple matter of removal
however
again looking at the guidance the
guidance suggests you should be
evaluating from nine meters back because
when you come to a giveaway there's an
expectation you should be prepared to
stop but you could also carry through
the intersection as clear so you need to
have
some visibility that some distance back
at stop control the expectation is you
come up to the limit line and come to a
stop and then should have better
visibility so it's not the
the
visibility impairments of these
relocations were that nine meter point
back when you actually get up to the
limit line at these you do have better
lines of sight down the road it's just
the expectation is you have to come to a
stop and then look and then make your
exit
um as mr harris has already indicated
that the issue of just becoming a bypass
in the future or driven to a bypass
that's used more often
do you think some education wouldn't go
miss as far as trying to
start gently removing some of the
impediments regarding hazards
when you have
at least looking at layman's road which
at this point still has very much of a
rural feel
um there are two main drivers towards
crashes at a priority section like that
one would be where you completely
misunderstood that you had to come to
and you had to give way to the through
road and the other is that you came to
stop and then misjudge traffic and
either misjudge the gap or discharge the
speed of somebody that got rear-ended
the first one
is a const acuity issue and that just
means making drivers on the layman's
roadside understand that they have to
come to a stop
and then
move on from there and that's not
necessarily a driver behavior
uh factor the second one where you are
either choosing to ignore the stop
control or misjudging the speed of
traffic that is a bit more of a driver
education issue
so i think there is definitely much to
be done around
in general raising the level of driver
education but it's not at this point
going to supplant the issues at these
locations where it really is a physical
impediment that
no amount of judgment or education can
supplant the fact that you can't see
around these impediments
um
that being said i think there is a much
bigger driver relationship yes thank you
any other questions
i hope we have a recommendation in front
of us
by kirsten secondly by jason
kirsten
um
very quickly i've been terrified of this
inception for many years and my driver
my daughter's just left to drive and she
is also
it's one intersection that we approach
as if there's a car coming every single
time so a soft one's not going to solve
the worst behavior but it is perhaps
going to make people think twice before
they drive straight through what has
happened on a few occasions so that was
an absolute no-brainer um a good drive i
was actually quite shocked how little
visibility i had coming from the east i
actually missed the car completely and
it's lemon grass um people like that
they're using that road as a bit of a
slalom at times and the speeds are
starting to increase so maybe something
we have to monitor just in terms of road
design because it's quite a fun road to
go quite fast on
so that intersection and as you see
around the district we're starting to
see vegetation creeping up on the
corners and it is something that we may
have to look at in our design guidelines
i think for intersections that are going
to have a fair volume of traffic
in my first term
we worked with ken's students and to put
in that and there's a picture there that
we opera island crossing
um one of the there's a picture there
with that white fence there
and that was one of the first residents
to say i was just about seeing someone
come back stunned tonight's way back in
the first year
um and now the problem is worse so you
know to live in this area as well as
houston said you are as quite surprising
when you drive there how
that
possibility is
as well
cool
you know i also support this but i still
think it's a lot of driver behavior
noting also that it was an accident the
one that evans wrote the other
week and put up the same committee
i think today with the
big group that um
apparently
one person actually did stop
the round in the giveaway and have a
look and then carried on and then the
accident happened so
stock time's not actually going to solve
the whole problem but also
i understand i think this is in the
speed review
at the moment as well so it could be a
double um safety scenario happening in
that area so
yes i think we need to sort some of
these out i think it's a lot of us
driver
what
is the um accident that happened at
belmont and oakwood drive actually
that's also down there as well something
yeah
um
i really think the solution for lenin's
road and one who come both
road would be to round us i think that's
what we need to aim for and long term um
because that
easter egg looks slow trip down be much
safer and i also know that um on the
limbs right friends i wrote i understand
and i may be wrong that there's been
some plantings and things there around
um the
the drainage areas which may be um also
obstructing some views so there's just
um observations that i have i may be
right i may be wrong but i believe the
solution for both
john's right or lemons right and friends
i know there's rendezvous you're quite
right joan you may be right or you may
be wrong
what i'd like to say is just some rumble
lines before the spotlight because the
vision here is people not stopping and
they need to be awake waking up 25
minutes 50 minutes before the stop's on
to put their phone away stop playing
with the stereo stop doing the hair or
shaving there's a problem
because
many times if you actually stop what
you're supposed to
give away it's actually quite clear
visibility
for lehman's children
so actually that you bring up a very
topical conversation we've been having
internally just today and i think um yes
the the changing the side roads to stop
patrol is the first step and we'll
continue to monitor in particular
layman's and john's because it does have
the history that it does have
if it turns out that the stop signs are
routinely being ignored for whatever
reason
then
we could evaluate rumble strips there
are
painted lines that
decrease the spacing between them to get
driver attention we can put also the
advanced warning signs stop ahead there
are a number of measures we can do to
try to
improve the constituting stop signs
um to make sure drivers are fully well
aware of them we will start with the
stop signs and see how once that is um
drivers are used to that and see how
they're behaving if that has improved
the sort of stance there and if not then
we'll look at further measures off the
road
we will be looking at some sites to
consider multiple strips they certainly
have a strong impact on motorists
they also tend to cause some plays so
when people get out there
in terms of uh
but we're looking to potentially uh
travel somewhere else
in
item 6.3 pages 3263
community boards discretionary ground
okay
good evening
[Applause]
two bronze requests
one from life education trust canterbury
which
i think we've all heard of we've seen
the trucks at various schools and
you're probably well aware of what they
do and
[Applause]
they're just looking for some funding to
help them continue until the end of the
2021 year
north canterbury swift club
this is a tricky one um
but obviously it's your decision
but
you know they're asking for quite a lot
of money
when we have indicated on our
application forms that the length of
them is 500
also if you're looking at 250 swimmers
they're looking to do a thousand ribbons
um
was
pretty uh straightforward so i'll answer
questions if i can
rocky
with regard to this
they indicated that if we only give 500
they're still going to
yes yes they do the question is sorry
the question is if the application is
signed the time will the project still
proceed the answer is yes
[Music]
right question about questions
just a question about the ribbons my
understanding is that even though
there's only 250 kids they're competing
in multiple events and they can get a
revenue every time they approve their
time
yeah probably thank you and that's
that's that's why that's actually not
totally clear
um well that's what it says in the
application
the well it says that they are just for
improving your time
okay
[Applause]
could i at the stage write just a small
technical
page 33 i think somebody's possibly felt
cold and wrong
and with respect i think it's been taken
from the application so
it's a long way out there i realized
well if no one's prepared test the
meeting i'll move i'll test the meeting
i'll move we grant 500 to the life
education trust and 500 to the north
canada
[Applause]
[Music]
that they would be sound
carried
item 6.4 expeditionary ground funding
criteria
age 64-70
okay
um i'll just introduce this but as this
was a
move from germany
trying to get some sort of clarity
but um
when discussing it was just this
afternoon
he did mention that in the funding
policy itself
that basically says that
if
a request comes through
from a school or an eot
the funding
policy requires
evidence
that that's not going to be spent on
ministry of educational
health things
so um
we are looking at actually adding that
into the
criteria to make us clearer
[Applause]
as you all know this has been an ongoing
issue for the board now for
many
years um
like peter allen had very firm views
that no school should get money from the
payers
uh the board has always taken a country
view
that if
if it's from
bbta or
a group associated with parents in the
school uh i think the classic one we
visited is north slovan community garden
for example this board has supported
that and so we should say
after the
three four months ago meeting where we
had further discussions on it i think
duncan
raised the issue
i contacted the other board cheers to
see what their thinking was and they all
said they had the same problem as we did
and see if we could
find some wording
that won't cover everything
uh but make it workable what the
suggestion is that the school itself
can't really apply ppta can an
understanding of there's a group
associated with the school
doing as a community effort then they
would also get you get it so this is a
quite crude way but if anyone can think
of a better way of trying to answer the
dilemma we would we would
the other chairs are happy with it
hence no they're not excluded hence just
saying there are other groups associated
with the school
and parents and things that might be
doing something in north london it was a
classic example totally acceptable to
the board
so if just because a school doesn't have
a pda doesn't mean that the parents or
the
community group around the school
is that often
schools might be organizing
something
that isn't
ministry funded but it's not it's being
organized by the board not by the ptac
um
for example our garden entertainment
program um
is often managed at a board level
no it's not run
organized by the pitch so
with this we would then have to ask our
pta at home in school to submit the
application on our behalf
when when it's not actually their
project that they are working does that
make sense so i'm yeah i'm just
concerned that that often boards are
doing things that the pta are involved
with
um
i think that's one of the differences
you've got and i can't see any way
around that to be quite interesting
just just in the criteria
and that's what we looked at here today
criteria this is just about actually the
pta gets the parts that the board
doesn't if it's
applied
but in the criteria i think it's about
i'll point you to it
um
one two three four five six seven
eight
nine ten eleven
10 down it talks about central
government funding so if the government
applies
all it has to do is we put the criteria
in there that has to specify that it's
not funded by central government
if it does that uh the board's got a
direction that can actually
improve the violence okay
thanks jeff they're clarified
um it does but all i would say is um
maybe we need to think about the wording
because the way i read it essentially
says that all
trustees can't apply
so maybe we need to think about the
wording being more specific around if
your project
is ministry funded you cannot apply if
it's not ministry funded you can
[Applause]
to me it reads that if you're a board of
trustees you can't apply
that's what it's
yes it does
if you've got any suggestions
other than an application
that is not
government-funded
or something words yeah we can
put something in there yeah
i think it just seems to be terrified
that if everyone's happy this is
government-funded you cannot before if
everyone's happy on the concept
and need to jump and the chair to
reword it to fit in their criteria i
think it's in the spirit of what we're
trying to do you know
yeah so if you're happy with that
that's right i'm confused i i don't
think
the board of trustees needs to be in
there it just needs to be directly
from a school receiving central funding
for their project or something but
that's not the woo board of trustees it
doesn't matter who's applying from the
school just matters that it's not not
central government
well we can have it we can have a look
at that because we need to talk to the
other board the other boards too so we
understand the intent but it's actually
for country schools it is going to cause
problems
just to
let you know that oxford
has often not has opted to retain the
status quo because they feel that the
criteria already
mentions that
um and wouldn't
was the same thing
to keep the status quo
so i don't know if the board might want
to
to keep the status quo but then reword
what we've got in the
criteria and just highlight more
um
the fact that evidence is required
i think i'll be able to move the
directions
okay
and evidence is required that it is not
funded through supervision
[Music]
involved it doesn't matter if you've
bought a trustee it doesn't matter if
you're pta if you're a parent you're a
teacher everybody's involved in smaller
schools
and we do have quite a few country
schools in our world
as well and of course rivera doesn't
have a specific pta as well
i've never had a problem with
applications coming from school because
we have the word discretionary
discretionary means you look at the
application on its merits you decide is
it going to be good for the children
do you decide is that going to be
something that the government should be
funding and you make the call at the
board and we vote on it i like the fact
it's been clarified because i think it
will help um stop debate and i really
appreciate what the chairs have done to
try and help clarify that for us to give
us a clearer direction but i didn't
think we need to specify the wording of
what group it is i think it was more the
point that schools should be responsible
for their core activities from using
central government funding but
discretion activities can come to the
board for our small clinical clinic that
we can get them so i'd be more
comfortable to keep the status quo but
replying the wording is being suggested
speaking to it i'm very i'm very happy
with that because the chair did not
write the recommendation it came from
start
it was our object was the secret way
forward and i think i think it was close
yet as we can get
so that's good other speakers
all right i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi
carrie
item seven
support
[Applause]
the cheers report which will include the
other report
um
be received
move to the second of bo duncan all
those in favor please say i
carry
item nine methods for information
okay
um again
you will have received an email this
afternoon hopefully again you'll see it
tonight
that there should have been another item
added on 0.14
which was in relation to the council's
adoption of no opt-in on three waters
that members might find interesting
members of the public be aware that the
of the council's direction and feeling
on the matter
thank you i'm happy to move that with
the addition of nine point one four
seconded for that
paul i'm just why we don't normally
debate these i just think it's
appropriate to say
to our counselors here i think that the
council has handled this issue
really
really well and i congratulate them on
that it's a tricky issue it's on it's
still ongoing
uh
but but well done to them i just brought
this along so
not humorous but it's a letter to the
editor i think it was in the odt
about written by a farmer from waimati
called robin watson
who told of a visit of a delegation from
wellington
uh to inspect a farming
district with a rural water schemes so
they came down from wellington to
inspect it
as part of the inspection they drove up
a very steep track to the top of the
hill to get an elevated view of
waterskiing as most of you know rural
schemes have tanks high up and then they
free drain
down
after some discussion
one of the people from wellington asked
was it not difficult for the water
tanker truck to climb such a steep hill
to fill the water tank
now the latter the editor goes on
that's the level of ignorance that has
been used to deal with this issue
i just thought i'd share that i know we
don't normally do that but check with me
anyway
okay
so all those in favor please say hi
carrie
[Applause]
paul and joan we looked at a train
at king street with a few issues
and i attended a district band meeting
in this world thank you
sarah
not too much really um both famously
with coco clinics and that's been a lot
since they started
um
but we did end up meeting we'll spoke to
you about this job i was trying to live
interview with peter but ray the
president from the children's box from
phone here several times
so dana and i met with hum
he had a vocalist
and the main thing that they want to do
is extend their building east
they have got a huge membership
um
in the field that they can't
and they haven't got the room amount of
people to come and play these table
bowls
they felt that on the other side the
croquet club program club
we're getting everything and they were
getting nothing so we were able to
settle a few rumors that weren't quite
true
so we're going to organise cloud and
chris brown to meet with
the president and
see if there's anything we can do for
the future
that's kind of where that's at
have you involved robbing a
the secretary is going to be in touch
with robbie and chris
that's good
joe
thank you
of course we've all been um busy with
drop-ins for the district plan happening
when covered allows
rainbow promotions had a meeting with
them last night and
they're proceeding with um celebration
night on the 19th of november
um god willing with covert and all that
sort of thing and also proceeding
with cowboy hopefully for the
christmas parade
but of course
you know everything is so uncertain at
the moment
that
much they're proceeding positively
towards these
these events
yeah of course with um moss header
meeting at central drainage advisory
group um and then um
yes there's been a lot of interest in
the district planned and the drop-ins
and i think people mostly are struggling
with um navigation on the website and
they need some help there so
we're having more drop down sessions
happening there to try and help people
with that um and of course tomorrow
morning at 7am i'm off to zone 5 6
meeting thursday and friday um to see
what's going to happen and see
hopefully they have what pressure we can
put on for three waters
and other items that are affecting local
government new zealand and all those
sort of things that are affecting um our
district
so that's me for the next couple of days
yeah jane could i just ask you there's
been quite a bit
in the news recently about councils
popping out of local government new
zealand
see timaru has i see christchurch is
considering it has our council had any
discussions on that i ask that because
well i think local government new
zealand's executive should be absolutely
wrong that's my view but opting out
leaves them in total control and i'm not
sure that that's necessary in the best
interest i just wondered if our council
has had any discussions
no no i'm not talking about opt out of
three waters i'm talking about opting
out of local government
dan is wanting to and i think he was on
a zoom call with local government new
zealand this morning at 8 30 um he's
wanting to he's asking questions of them
and we'll be asking questions of them in
the next couple of days as well i think
it's a preference that
that but one of the requirements that we
have is that we're really really unhappy
with that they signed an mao mou
before the conference which was held in
venom without consulting the delegates
they're getting the um and and said that
they would not oppose the government
mandating um
uh importing three three waters before
without consulting so we're really
unhappy about that and we want them to
retract that but at this stage i think
that
the consensus is on dan's view
is that
we need to to ask we've asked them we've
sent a letter asking them
to
retract
um
the
that that they would um not oppose
mandating the threat orders reform and
if they're not prepared to do that we're
seriously looking at withdrawing from
the museum
thank you for clarifying that
so interesting
addition to that i think the council
is saying on the stage it's better to
stay inside again
if it ops out of the government new
zealand it sort of shows that
just you know then it's sort of breaking
apart and it shows that we've got
uniform
that's why
you're much better to try and roll and
exec and get rid of them yeah well dan's
actually calling for a special meeting
too yeah well that's excellent i think
russian city's family
quite a clever game too um i've asked
for a staff report
and what this stuff will cover is what
local government new zealand has done in
the past three years
well that's good idea and that concerns
the mighty processors
press that
um the other thing that's just come out
as the government reviewing
that scope's number and that looks like
another dia supported document
which we'll probably also eventually
have
some concerns with even though it's
being led by
our institute
thank you jim
um
firstly i'd actually like to really
apologize again for not being at um a
number of our previous meetings
um
so do a contest about it um the only
thing i've really been involved with is
pool from the roading uh as you all know
i love gravel roads
and so
that's what i hear a lot from everybody
around me
and we had some new gravel put down
near my house and it is fantastic i have
a great i mean i'm very lucky
but um
look it hasn't been greater than three
months and it's as good as it happened
yeah
um
so we're really encouraged to
see that and
and i know that paul's pretty excited
about it so
just kind of keep wandering there on
paul's eyes on the ground
yeah fantastic hasn't scoured out with
the rain around it
it's really quite impressive i did
explain to the board at the last meeting
you were unable to
come to that i recommended you not to
come because you were going to put your
life at risk i thought driving out the
night so the board understood that
totally thank you
um as you know i did attend the um all
boards planning
on the 22nd september
on behalf of gym i attended southport
working
road working party
yeah i i found that
quite interesting and and when you get
involved
i think the board does need to
focus on the issue this is about
improvement of safety in south brooklyn
there's improvement on the safety of the
people that walk the pavement and
actually get out of their cars is
against the other 20 or so thousand that
simply drive through and out the other
end every day
and i think when people start talking
about the improvements it is safety
improvement the people who commute uh
there could be an initial effect or even
slightly slowing down the traffic but i
think it's you know important that we
understand it's a safety improvement for
the people within
that area
so that was
and also i attended the blessing of the
council chambers
on your behalf and i attended the
drainage meeting on the 7th of october
and i also like to concur with andrew's
issues regarding gravel road very nice
as you're indicating it is
the wider issue that we need to address
perhaps possibly as a board and
i know it's always the argument there's
only five percent of the traffic
movements in the district each day are
on gravel roads but as we move into
november and the council look at their
funding i think we need to have a
cross-section or even a report as to the
state of our shingle rage because i i do
believe they're in deficit and they've
been a deficit for a number of years as
in the state of them and possibly
spending on them
so i think councils need to have a just
a bit of a look around
because we caught the criticism um and
that there are some nice things in
waimakariri that people go to see and
enjoy
and some people still simply probably
can't feel they're not getting the
basics
so i think that issued the uh if the
gravel road issue is being successful
and you believe it's a way forward
um perhaps we need some more of it thank
you
thank you
question
um yes
the other issue obviously the flood
recovery is sort of coming to an end
still a few issues with bridges and
leeds valley obviously
but just to let you know that it costs
2.8 million
so to get the aware that that event has
and that's obviously got to be just
a few months deficit
so
the
extreme weather events we're facing uh
getting loose and they seem to be hidden
in the form of polarity which doesn't
help the rain issue at all
and
i'm actually quite concerned about the
state of their arterial roads because
they seem to be getting patched and
patched in a pitch and that's funding
that's wha
we had absolutely no say over there
because
arterial roads are not
hierarchy to get in addition to london
so that's where we need to push
eventually to say that actually
[Applause]
particularly
and
to maintain roads
but i can't see they're getting any
better with the current state of the
budget
from what i've seen so it's a really
really difficult for us to do and
but i do certainly appreciate all the
work that paul's done on gravel roads we
have a lot of problems that have come as
well
and we are seeing that the i think
perhaps some of the
monitoring hadn't been done quite as
regularly as it could have and i think
that's been tidied up so i'm hoping
you'll see it along the way
um a major event and there's still some
work to do we've still got bridges we've
still got ford's closed throughout the
district and ecandom repairs and that's
proving a very long slowing process um
which is cutting off resilience in
different parts
and and does i think some of our
residents in some from other worlds as
well
and obviously the oklahoma area was
still hit very bad and there's still a
lot to be done there
about
river protection and what we're going to
do in terms of river ratings and so on
um the other
casualty
of the three winners discussion has also
been the rating review on three waters
we have wanted to look at trying to
um we're getting some of our rural
sleeves and paint such huge amounts for
water and we've had the town schemes
paid quite a little and we were looking
at what we could do to try and balance
access to water across the district that
was going to be reviewed in 2022 because
of the current circumstances that has
now been deferred
um so that will not hit the issue until
we're much better about what's happening
with rewards
so those are the right things
got my own um about our water not
necessarily drinking water rivers etc
yeah contamination of themselves yeah
it's interesting
that's not in the three waters review
yeah the rivers are not included
it was false advertising
where you saw them included
i also need to keep running your
beautiful women
meetings as well yes yeah
i don't mean don't don't mention this
person for the rest of your cable house
business
not really not really in place
why don't you
um i was approached by someone regarding
what could be accountable house and
phrasal place that appears to have sort
of been popped on site
and it's on its
and it's quite an eyesore and people
aren't very happy apparently
um
i mean it's obviously a working produce
and hopefully in time it will look a bit
better but another neighbors commented
about really capable houses to me and
how
they don't give any notification about
houses that are coming to that land
beside them and suddenly they arrive
there and i wonder i don't know what can
be done about it
something can be improved to make people
aware of what's coming so the neighbors
can say something before it happened
i don't know it's probably not not worth
chasing up anyway
joe
i don't have to hear
that that house and fraser place was due
to be dropped this week
um
onto its foundations which are ready to
go but because of the wet weather that
has been planted
thank you thank you jason
sadly nothing too interesting to report
don't be shy about it
the last meeting i reported
i have a beauty thing back
as i mentioned earlier about the meeting
next week for a bit of
an update
there has been another fire of the
transfer station a couple weeks ago
probably caused by the
so we're looking at some
mechanisms that will hopefully
fix the battery
factory issue we had a
reasonably brief hearing yesterday on
the local body
arrangements rich
only 15 submissions
so
i don't think it's going to be
incredible
paul
i actually have asked the staff to do a
report on the roadings around the whole
of waimakariri and that's coming to
council and there will be a ruling i've
asked to come to
um
maintenance and all that so that is
coming so it's been asked for it's a
matter of getting a bit of
the rolling staff that have been known
under the
it's all coming together um
i've also been involved with it with
this local government debacle um i was
probably i don't know lucky or unlucky
but
two of their councillors were as philly
and myself were invited to
cross the city councils and
councils
invited us to get our opinion on
local government and i think it was
because i was one of the councils within
the local government conference and
phillip riemann was and um
so
in actual fact why macabre council
leader we were then put into
christchurch council's decision here
and it is a politic and they don't
really want to pull out but they want
local government become a bit more
democratic for numbers because it's not
running the democratic situation so
um for example i went to the local
government conference
i've been to christchurch
for the agm they always had space for a
counsellor to sit in the back this time
they wouldn't let the counselors in they
turned them down
it was only by appointment only um
you get in and there were seats left
there
of myself were both terms at the door as
were other councillors from other
councils around new zealand which
didn't go down very well at all but
that just shows you
what's happening in the local government
new zealand so i was
horrified of internally at the door
so um
the other thing wakataki's um
[Music]
in ltp is announced earlier september
and the council has been really lucky
they've got
a key project the south fork road and
coronation specialisation is going ahead
right
that the park and foreign side is going
to get a bit of attention and screw
bridge and mulcox road intersection
improvements that's been passed
unfortunately other
funding requests weren't met
and that's one billion
dollars short for the maintenance of
operations and rural renewals budgets
only half of the budget for low-cost
low-risk projects were awarded
6.6 million out of 13.2 million and this
does impact on the safety of our roads
around waimakariri
i was really disappointed because our
staff
did a really good job
and as it turned out it probably wasn't
so good we trimmed everything into the
bone to keep the rates down and
put in their plans exactly what we
wanted to do
and um
which was was good and unfortunately the
government turned around and gave a 50
percent pretty much split through all
councils so all the councils that didn't
from their budget were
to the bone and uh even though they
couldn't even do what they still got the
same procedure so um
and i'm really disappointed because
the government seemed to have lead you
money they're giving away to a
donation to magma mob
the isis still giving money away to you
know there seems to be plenty of money
there um
and also the forum today with the road
safety and the trucking division
um
we took the
uh
hey 2.4 billion dollars into the the
road network and apparently 1.1 million
that was um
transferred elsewhere so um
yeah it's a little disappointing with
the way the funding was working there
but
i mentioned that angela mentioned about
the barriers on the motorway
double width barriers
on there
the government spending a lot of money
on those barriers we are
there's been no accidents and yet places
like the woody
area where there's been documented
accidents and all that ramen seems to
miss out
on some of those safety products and um
take away the barriers for example we
could have had a million dollars towards
some of their safety parts their roads
that we need so
it's a double-head store but i i'm very
disappointed with the way that the
government's done the
yeah that's we've had a lot of
three waters debate and um
i don't know whether we're winning or
not hopefully dean would probably be um
more knowledgeable us
i personally think
the government is starting to get a bit
worried about um
60 council about 67
wanting to
pause and what you do and
i think dean's been doing a really good
job soon i know he's getting the three
waters getting mentioned but
um yeah he's put a lot of effort into
that and you know i thank him for doing
that as well thank you
thank you thanks paul
right moving on item 11 is for your
information
there uh
item 12 boards funding the discretionary
grant that's giving you your balances
and the general landscape
balance there the 25
970 plus carryover
hasn't yet been determined here is that
right
okay
okay thank you
i don't think there's any media items or
no questions there's no urgent general
business
and
just before we go into
workshop
and
we have to
consider the district plan
uh
and there was quite a lot i think for
the board
to consider and discuss
it seems
torn decay would be appropriate to have
a special
workshop
meeting for that sometime
shortly i
some accounts will get involved
and will be involved in the hearing so
it's
not necessary for
you guys if you don't want to i think
but you're always welcome
so what
any proposed dates came or
i did contact the team and the dates
they gave me were
thursdays the fourth of the eleventh
thursday the 26th of the 10th
well i think what we might be best at at
what time of the day was the staff
wanting to do that did you give me a
time but i would
suspect five o'clock would be quite a
good time but if you wanted it later no
i think anyone could find
what would
cale put around those days and if you've
been back to her
which ones you're suitable most suitable
for you will find the most appropriate
days and if you
comment on the time
suggestions 5 o'clock
at the stage
so
okay you have to put that around your
board members robbie and the weather
no it's you and i scheduled for 3 30
however
okay
we'll do that now so
that brings us to an end of our formal
meeting part and now we're moving to
workshop we've got a workshop we've got
a workshop we've done a workshop we've
done workshop we've done a workshop
we've done workshop we've done workshop
we've done we're